uh warnings of a truly dark day for
drivers as petrol prices hit a record
high across the uk the average price for
elite of petrol reached
142.94 pence on sunday this is according
to data that's come from the rac and
experian catalyst well for more on this
i'm joined by the fuel spokesperson for
the rac simon williams simon good
afternoon to you
good afternoon sarah jane and i'll start
with the obvious question uh petrol
price is at a record high now why
uh the price of oil has gone up it's
doubled in a year uh it was at 40 a year
ago now at 85 and probably you know
going further north unfortunately but
also the exchange rate is uh lower than
it was about 13 down on
2012 when we had the last record high
um and that's important because fuel
like oil is traded in dollars so we need
the pound to be strong against the
dollar and it's weaker now in fact in
2012 oil was 118 dollars a barrel
uh so that's obviously made an impact
and also we now have more biofuel in a
liter of petrol uh ethanol was the
amount of ethanol was increased in
september when we moved to e10 petrol
uh and that added uh about nine pence a
liter overall for the mix
so that means now that uh the pure
petrol elements around 42 pence and the
bio element is nine pence
and the retailers too are taking more
margin than they did back in 2012 they
were taking around three and a half feet
of a liter then
now we're up to about
uh nine pence and that's probably
something we saw probably just before
the pandemic and it's got worse during
the pandemic and they're kind of trying
to make up for lost time
and then you've got duty and bat duties
are 58 pence and v8 you know equates to
23 pence uh alicia and that's gone up
about 3 p.m since uh a year ago yeah
let's talk about tax um in the uk tax
accounts for 57
of the average retail price
for petrol uh the budget's coming up on
wednesday the cost of living a huge
issue at the moment and petrol being
able to get about is a a part of that
for for many families up and down the
country and do you think the petrol vat
needs to be looked at by the chancellor
on wednesday
uh absolutely we wouldn't normally be
calling for due to be duty to be frozen
uh or cut
um but due to the change of behavior
from retailers we think that uh a v80
cut would be far more beneficial and
obviously we've with cop26 and that
there's obviously a lot of pressure on
the move to zero emission driving so i
think uh going back to seventeen and a
half percent vat would take three p a
liter off and if the retailers were then
to put things up you know that would be
um not so bad as actually you know
cutting v80 and then that being absorbed
but it's obviously very difficult from a
driver's point of view lots of people
would love to go electric but at the
moment the high upfront costs are still
off-putting
and that means that people on the lowest
incomes are in the worst possible
position there aren't enough electric
vehicles on the second-hand car market
at the moment they used to still filter
through
and they are then paying some very you
know extortionate prices at the pumps
and if they're unlucky enough to drive a
car that isn't compatible with e10 then
they could be paying one pound 55 a
liter for the super unleaded which is
still available at the e5 level yeah
simon drivers are really getting a
double triple whammy depending on where
you live in the country because of
course price of petrol going up it's not
just going to affect individuals it's
going to affect businesses as well and
we know that the knock-on effect of that
is increased costs in all areas of our
life that again
affects every one of us so that's the
double whammy and then if you live in
london for example um the pollution
charge zone is being expanded 18 times
greater and as you've just pointed out
there a lot of people that need to drive
live in the poorest parts of the country
and have to get into cities
yes and we know from rec research that
people are even more reliant on their
car now they may not be driving quite as
many miles
but receive research shows them more
reliant on their cars and that's partly
because there's been a loss of
confidence in public transport since
covid i understanding that people had to
rely on their cars more you know for
getting to work
for going to look after family and
friends
to get the shopping uh all these reasons
and as you say businesses are also going
to feel it too we're not far off a
record price for diesel as well we're
about penny and a half away from that
that's 147.93
again achieved in april 2012. uh and i
don't think there's any particular end
in sight unfortunately some analysts are
predicting oil is going to get to 90 a
barrel
and if it was to get to 100 i think we'd
probably see one pound 50 on average
across the uk that's a pretty
frightening price and that's going to
cause all kinds of economic negative
impact
yeah i mean those figures my director
just whistled in my ear when you said
that last figure because of course you
know people do rely on their cars and
it's not just you know for frivolous
trips as you said to get to work to get
essentials and this is a really serious
issue and the budget on wednesday
i mean would you accept even a temporary
measure from the chancellor as i said
the cost of living is
you know the hot topic right now and
he's under pressure from all sides to do
things that will affect families right
now not in the next year or two
we have to recognize there are problems
with the client we need to move towards
zero emission driving but i think a
temporary cut to the at seventeen and a
half percent would help households up
and down the country and so we really
urge him to do that
we know that there's going to be a big
impact from people not being able to
drive not be able to put enough money
into that
to fill up their car it's it's going to
be you know tough times and i i can't
see it getting better for any time soon
we'd urge retailers also to do their bit
the biggest retailers could um reduce
their margin a bit and that would help
as well because that's that's all kind
of before v80 is applied too yeah
and you think it was sorry we just had a
little camera issue in the studio here
if you heard a big crash it's okay it's
still on the wall and that's why i was
going to say simon retailers of course
you think it would be good for them
actually to cut the price of their fuel
because of course people will head to
their outlets rather than competition
yeah we have quite a lot of sympathy for
the smallest retailers they've struggled
to keep going during the pandemic and of
course the fuel supply prices also hit
them pretty hard because while it
started out as a bigger retailer issue
it meant everyone bought all the fuel
and then the smaller retailers with the
weaker supply chain struggled to get
their uh supplies back into get enough
stock back into the ground so i think
the biggest retailers would you do the
biggest margin actually still had the
shoppers coming to them during uh
during the pandemic could afford to kind
of reduce their margin again and that
would help everyone uh probably bring
the average price down across the
country uh and help people carry on be
able to get to work affordably yeah it's
very hard to find a winner in all of
this at the moment um simon williams
from the rac thank you very much for
joining us here on sky news talking
about that new uh record high price for
petrol the average now
142.94 pence and as you heard simon
there
that number looks set to go up